joe biden vacations and aoc heads to
florida as oh macron spikes well the
media as always target ron desantis and
the democratic media complex prepares
for a january 6th
extravaganza i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressivevpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment and there's so much of it
because i've been missing you guys first
let's talk about one of the best
investments you can make it is in
yourself this is why grand canyon
university an affordable private
christian university is one of the
largest fastest growing universities in
the country located in sunny phoenix
arizona gcu has not increased campus
tuition since 2009 they've delivered
over 290 million dollars in scholarships
to online and campus students in 2020
alone gcu offers 275 degree programs
with over 250 of those online so if
you're looking to earn your degree
online with supportive counselors and
faculty from around the country or you
want to go to one of the top 20 best
college campuses in america where you
truly feel connected to a community find
your purpose at grand canyon university
it's private christian affordable visit
gcu.edu my offer to see what
scholarships you qualify for i visited
gcu student body is fantastic it's a
beautiful campus and honestly it's the
new year so it's time to resolve to get
your education in order if you're
looking for a credential so you can move
up in your career gcu is a great way to
do it visit gcu.edu
my offer see what scholarships you
qualify for from grand canyon university
alrighty so
over the break everyone continued to
panic about omicron but not as much as
they were before not as much as they
they were before because here is the
thing
for so many people in the united states
they've been viewing covet as a pagan
god visiting
upon their enemies
if you were a blue state person then
every time florida had a spike you
pointed at florida you said those guys
they're bad because they voted for ron
desantis and that is why there's a big
spike in florida
and every time california looked over at
texas and there was a spike in text that
ah those people are evil and that's why
this is happening well there's only one
problem now
omicron has come and omicron is going to
be gotten by everyone everyone's going
to get omicron we're all getting it i've
been saying this since it broke it is
140 times as transmissible as the
original variant it is 70 times as
transmissible as delta now the really
really good news is it is also about 20
as deadly as delta which means that it
is about as deadly as delta would be
after you were vaccinated for delta so
you unvaccinated with omicron you have
about the same odds as you would be
vaccinated with delta right that's the
south african stats
which means that you know that's not all
that scary like it really is not and a
bunch of people in the blue states are
starting to get omicron despite having
done all the things that their great
scientific authorities told them to do
they now have a challenge because they
can either look at their worldview and
realize that covid was not a pagan god
covet is in fact just a disease and it
has certain vectors and you can do
certain things to mitigate against the
risks of the disease like getting
vaccinated if you are unhealthy or if
you are elderly
or if you are in a very crowded area
theoretically you could be wearing an
n95 mask although not quite as effective
against omocron as it was against prior
variants right but that's pretty much
all you can do and also even if you get
vaccinated you're probably gonna get
omicron
instead of seeing the virus is just a
challenge in life
against which you have to make certain
risk-reward calculations the left
started to see it as this pagan god well
once homocron came we are back to basic
risk reward calculations because you're
getting punished whether you did the
right thing or the wrong thing whether
you got vaxxed or unvaxed whether you
are living in new york or living in
florida there is a spike where you live
because omicron is really transmissible
and so this challenge is the world view
you have two choices choice number one
is to suddenly discover all the things
that some of us have been saying for
well over a year and realize that you
have to live with a certain level of
risk in your life
or a possibility too is you have to
crack down even harder if only we had
shown more fealty to the health
authorities if only we listened more to
dr fauci if only we worshipped more at
the altar of joe biden then perhaps
omicron would spare us and you can see
this bifurcation happening on the left
it's really fascinating so i want to
begin with just a couple of brief stats
because i know that stats are verboten
where many on the on the militant
coveted lockdown left come from okay
here are the current
deaths in california okay they're
averaging about 65 deaths a day in
california
okay as you see this number is actually
lower than it was back in september
this despite the fact that the case
count in california has indeed been
going up
that is not a surprise because again
omicron is not nearly as deadly as delta
right that's the case count the case
count is
going to like on a daily basis it will
be the highest it has ever been in
california in very short order they are
seeing something like 60 000 new cases
every day in california right now and
they're seeing 65 deaths a day this is
not unique to california
if we take a look at some of the other
states you will see that this is the
consistent pattern and by the way it's
the consistent pattern at every every
place on earth here are the deaths in
new york
hey are you noticing something about the
deaths in new york that's correct there
has been no significant increase in the
number of deaths in new york seven day
running average 33 in new york here is
what the case chart looks like okay the
case chart looks like an exponential
spike they're seeing 45 000 new cases a
day in new york
okay so
why but but
are you going to let go of this guys are
you going to or are you not
right the cognitive dissonance is too
great on the one hand covet is only
supposed to hit the unworthy on the
other hand it's hitting everyone and
very few people are dying so what do you
do what do you do by the way florida
right you'll see the media covering
florida oh the death in florida oh the
chaos in florida 22 deaths on the seven
day rolling average
okay 24 deaths december 31st 2021
okay these are lower numbers than they
were seeing in mid-september
why because again omicron not super
deadly hey thank god this is a good
thing like except the good news guys
here's that case count in florida 76 000
new cases december 31st hey now one of
the reasons you're seeing a lot of new
cases because everyone is testing you
can go all over the country and you're
seeing giant lines of people who are
testing for omicron and honestly i don't
understand the logic i don't
the only logic seems to be that
everybody is stuck in the march 2020
mindset in which a covid
a coveted diagnosis meant that you were
supposed to absolutely panic and freak
out
i don't even understand if you're
asymptomatic or mildly symptomatic for
covid they're not going to do anything
for you on a treatment level i was
talking to my wife about this yesterday
she's like i am completely unaware of
any medical perspective from which you
are supposed to test people for a
disease when it does not actually change
your treatment vectors
in other words why test for something if
you don't
change how you're going to treat the
thing right you don't go get tested for
the cold why because there's nothing you
can do about the cold you just have the
cold and then you're done the only
reason to do this is because you still
think you can stop transmission you're
not stopping transmission of omicron
okay so
here's the reality for a lot of people
on the left they know this a lot of
people on the left know this and they're
beginning to they're beginning to accept
the reality not fully accepted not
intellectualize it but but sort of
accept it in practice and even in some
of their rhetoric so you started to see
this over the course of the last week
and a half so joe biden the president of
the united states who once tweeted that
he was going to stop the virus which of
course he has not because no one can
because it's a virus
here here is president biden this is
late december saying there is no federal
solution for covet which is weird
because last i checked he's attempting
to mandate that all of my employees be
vaccinated or he will find me
which is so for a guy who says he has no
control he seems to be trying to assert
an extraordinary amount of control
here's the president of the united
states saying well that is not my fault
there is no
federal solution this gets solved at a
state level i'm looking at governor
sununu on the board here he talks about
that a lot and it ultimately gets down
to
where the rubber meets the road and
that's where the patient is in need of
help or preventing the need for help
all righty well um
i know that you can't solve this why
don't you accept that you can't solve
this by the way joe biden then took off
for delaware so this we have to we have
to sort of recapitulate what happened
over the break because it's quite
fascinating and it shows you how the
media have spun the american public out
of control here so joe biden says there
is no federal solution then he promptly
leaves for delaware it just takes off
for delaware in the middle of this giant
omicron spike now theoretically we shall
be panicking right giant now in reality
none of us should be panicking right
we've done all we can there are measures
you can take if you wish to protect
yourself that's about there's joe biden
just walking away catch you later see it
in delaware bob
bye
so he just walks away
meanwhile the irrepressible
unbelievably fresh so fresh so face
magnificently stupid alexander
ocasio-cortez she decamped from lock to
town new york city where everybody is
still masked but they have vast mandates
despite the fact that the vaccinated are
still passing the disease she decamped
to florida
and she was down here
in in death scientists hellscape right
down here in my state
vacationing with her boyfriend
isn't that isn't that nice like that's
so nice she left a locked down state
that she helped create
to come down here to my state which she
is constantly ripping on as a hellscape
death santis
burning flaming
dante seventh circle
carnage ridden
landscape of of horror
she decamped down here so she could
vacation in the sun
because she's a terrible person because
she decamped here and then when people
pointed out hey aoc it's weird because
you're vacationing in the state that you
keep talking about is being the worst
right ronda sanchez is going to get
everybody killed and he doesn't care if
people die and yet here you are enjoying
the sun and the fun with your boyfriend
she tweeted out in response if
republicans are mad they can't date me
they can just say that instead of
projecting that
projecting their sexual frustrations
onto my boyfriend's feet you creepy
weirdos
so her response to you are a
flaming
ridiculous hypocrite for moving from
your lockdown state down here to
vacation
while constantly muleing that
republicans are killing everyone and yet
you're here i noticed you don't seem
that afraid i noticed it seems like in
your personal life when you're not
parking your tesla illegally at the
whole foods you're decamping to florida
for vacation
when we notice that her response is it's
just because you want to have sex with
me well maybe it's cause you're a
maybe that's the problem maybe it's
because you're a stupid maybe it's
because you're a giant stupido maybe
it's because you have the brain power of
like the little oven lights in the easy
bake ovens that i get my daughter
like maybe it's because you are one of
the dumbest people alive that's why we
are pointing this out
and then she tweeted out it's starting
to get old ignoring very obvious strange
deranged sexual frustrations that
underpin the republican fixation on me
women and lgbt plus people in general
is she gay now i miss that part these
people clearly need therapy won't do it
and use politics as their outlet instead
it's really weird
no what's really weird is that we point
out that you are a ridiculous human
being and your first response is well
that's just because you want to screw me
if somebody has a problem here lady i
have a feeling it's you
by the way she is she was having lots of
fun over the over the week right she she
camped here she was um apparently
she was called up on stage at a uh drag
queen bar at a drag bar in florida
you know unmasked with a bunch of people
in close proximity with one another you
know living afraid as we were supposed
to taking all precautions as necessary
[Applause]
there she is oh smiling oh there we are
just
man these folks these folks okay so
i i will say this uh the the media's
treatment of this is truly astonishing
so they didn't ask why joe biden is
headed off to delaware they don't care
right he's going to delaware it's fine
it's fine the man needs his nap and he
needs his insure and he needs his
matlock and it's christmas break so why
the hell not
and they don't care that aoc is
decamping down to florida to enjoy
vacation in the land of sun and fun that
she decries as once again a landscape
of of death
they don't care about any of that what
they care about is where's rhonda census
literally the day after joe biden just
absconded
they decided you know where's ron
desantis and this started running on
twitter where's ron desantis where's ron
desantis where's rhonda sanses where's
ron well it turns out that where was ron
desantis
it turns out that um ron desantis was
taking care of his wife
who's having cancer treatments
so that's nice
apparently he took his wife to cancer
treatments over christmas break and
meanwhile aoc was tweeting out about ron
desantis
she tweeted hasn't governor desantis
been inexplicably missing for like two
weeks if he's around i would be happy to
say hello his social media team seems to
have been posting old photos for weeks
in the meantime perhaps i could help
with local organizing folks are quite
receptive here smiley face yeah come
down here and try to run aoc let's see
how that goes for you really really pick
a district anytime anytime or
alternatively just stay the hell out of
my state because you don't belong here
seriously go away just go away
it's a free country you're allowed to be
here i'm not saying we should legally
borrow you from entering the state i'm
saying that you're
that
if you are going to crap all over the
state where i live and then come here
for vacation
and then rip on the governor who's done
all the things that you did not want to
do
you should maybe just stay home maybe
you should just go home you jackass
maybe that but honestly this is how i'm
feeling about about about all of this
stuff lately the reason i'm feeling this
is because there are newfound
discoveries happening each and every day
from the left about things that all of
us those of us who've been listening to
the show those of us who've been
following the data
there are many things that we have been
saying for well over a year and some
things we've been saying for a couple of
months since omicron that you guys have
been ignoring and yet suddenly it has
dawned upon you like a ray of light from
the heavens the clouds opened
suddenly the voice broke forth the voice
not of god but god is a woman
ariana grande's voice came down from the
heavens and suddenly you were bestowed
with vast wisdom with regard to covet
that some of us have been saying by
looking at the data for the last several
months we'll get to that in just one
second first let us talk
about the chair that you need speaking
of things that come directly from heaven
i've spoken to you before of the magic
of the ex-chair well it's a brand new
year and what better time for you to
please your back and please your
buttocks than by getting the greatest
share of all time the ex-chair thanks to
my ex chair i look forward to sitting in
my office because my body feels much
more supported and comfortable more
comfort means more productivity helping
my extra pay for itself thanks to how
much more work i'm getting done every
single day and if i'm feeling stressed
or tight i just turn on that elemex
massage feature and choose from four
different massage options if the office
is running too hot or too cold you can
flip on that lmx temperature regulation
and you can either heat or cool your
back
once you feel the customized support of
x chairs patented dynamic variable
lumbar support your back will never be
happy in any other chair again take my
advice try extra for yourself risk free
for 30 days once you realize how much
better your chair should be you will
never go back i promise go to
exchairshapiro.com right now that's the
letter x chair
s-h-a-p-i-r-o.com or call one eight four
four four x-chair for a hundred dollars
off your order x-chair has a 30-day
guarantee of complete comfort you can
finance your purchase for as little as
30 bucks a month exchair shapiro.com
alright so
as i say i'm noticing that the democrats
are sort of acting
like republicans now but they're not
speaking like republicans or if they do
they're pretending that it's brand new
info breaking news
it wasn't that the republicans were
right all along it wasn't that
commentators who followed the data been
right all along it said there's new
information and this new information
changes everything
it is it's amazing how the new
information coincided directly with a
bunch of them and their friends getting
omgron right literally as soon as they
got a cold and they realized that this
wasn't the end of the world and that
they had done all of the things and that
god had still smoked them with omicron
at exactly that point in time they went
oh
maybe i should be able to go to work oh
maybe i shouldn't have to shut down my
business hey you know should we shut
down all of american society over all
this stuff
i am so frustrated you are so frustrated
we are all so frustrated you guys spent
almost two years you've spent almost two
years killing people's businesses
destroying their lives forcing their
kids out of school only to now turn
around and pretend that it has dawned
upon you like the prophets of old the
great truth from love
the same crap we've been saying for
months and at this point almost years
yeah you can shove it where the sun
don't shine man like my god okay so
we begin with chris hayes so chris hayes
over at msnbc he's saying about omicron
he says you know
you know
omicron get this guy's
omnicron is kind of like the flu
it's kind of like the flu
so here is the thing omicron is kind of
like the flu in terms of its infection
death rate right its infection fatality
rate is ifr is very close to that of the
flu by the available data you know what
else is very close to the ifr of the flu
post-vaccination delta
right if you're if you're unvaccinated
then delta's way more deadly than the
flu if you're post-vaccination then
delta is less deadly than the flu on an
ifr basis so is the original variant
once you're vaccinated you are good to
go and yet these people treated it as
panic time the entire time
if you even said that post-vaccination
you really should not be afraid you
should go and live your life and you're
fine
you're treated as a as a covet denier
now here's chris hayes and it has
suddenly dawned on him wait this thing
isn't so bad yeah we know asshat we know
here he is
those people who are vaccinated
particularly those who are boosted
you know the risk the personal risk of
of being exposed to this went from
something that we hadn't really dealt
with specifically like this before in
our lifetimes we hadn't quite had an
illness this infectious and this
possible to cause serious illness to
something that does look more like the
flu
and the flu of course can still be
dangerous kills tens of thousands of
americans every year but we don't orient
our lives around the flu
whoa wouldn't tucker carlson take over
chris hayes body that was weird that's
super strange
whoa
it's just dawning on them now guys it's
dawning on them now but they they're the
first to discover it
honest honestly goodness okay or how
about dr anthony fauci so dr fauci over
the break
he was talking about the fact that no
one in south africa is uh is vast like
the vaccination rate in south africa is
really low like 30 and yet no one in
south africa is dying of covet weird i
wonder why that could be
could it be wait that i'm going to say a
couple of words right here it's a phrase
the phrase we've used a lot on the show
doctors who've been on the show use it
as well because it has been known about
for literally a couple of thousand years
at this point
natural immunity once you have the
disease your body now knows how to fight
the disease i know this is crazy talk
because coveted was so new it was brand
new it was so special it was different
from every other disease in fact it's
not covered works like pretty much every
other disease but dr anthony faucet's
now dawning on him that natural immunity
is a thing but apparently still only in
south africa in the united states you
have to vax boost boost again in fact
you have to get that punch card and if
you finally get to 12 boosters then you
get a free donut and also they give you
a new punch card so you can start over
because it's more like your dry cleaners
than it is like an actual fulfillment of
some sort of curriculum right there will
never be an end to the boosters
according to anthony fashion but but
natural immunity does apply in south
africa so um yeah i didn't know that
biology was different in south africa
than here but according to fouchy here
is fouchy discovering natural immunity
it dawned on him for the first time with
omicron amazing
it is likely
that the reason that it is less severe
is that in south africa what you have is
a very large proportion of the
population has already been infected and
recovered and a relatively smaller
proportion have been vaccinated so it is
likely
that the protection against infection is
not very good because it will get into
the nasopharynx and infect you the
reason they may have a less severe is
that the underlying cross protection
that you have
from an experience of a virus of a
different variant
might actually be protecting you from
severe disease which predominantly
involves the lungs
i'm sitting here in sun silence because
some of us have been saying this for two
years okay and captain best doctor in
the world after dr joe biden is suddenly
discovering natural immunity well slow
clap for doctor for dr fought she slow
clap for the greatest infectious disease
specialist of our time slow clap for
discovering the same thing that we've
known for a couple of thousand years at
this point i'll get some more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that you are paying too much
for gas because you are paying too much
forecast i'm not going to name any names
names that rhyme with with shmoe briden
to blame for the high gas but i will say
that you are paying too much for gas and
that means you need the free get upside
app my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download that free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code shapiro
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back don't pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
just download that app for free use
promo code shapiro get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your very first
tank of gas some people who drive a lot
making hundreds of bucks a month in cash
back there is no catch the cash back
gets added directly to your account you
can cash out anytime to your bank
account paypal or any gift card for
amazon and other brands just download
that free get upside app use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your very first tank of gas
that is promo code shapiro
that free get upset app is going to make
you so much money and again there's
really no catching get the free get
upside app right now at the app store to
get started alrighty so
again i'm just amazed that that all of
our health experts all of our policy
experts are are just accepting the
reality now as we'll see not for long so
dr fauci made an incredible statement
over the course of the christmas holiday
christmas new year's holiday
the cdc made an announcement the
announcement was that if you are
diagnosed with covid then your
quarantine period should not be 10 days
your quarantine period should be five
days right once you're if you're
asymptomatic if your symptoms go away
then you should be able to go to work
after five days
now is this based in science the answer
is no it is not based in science you
know why because nothing the cdc does is
based in science six feet of social
distancing not based in science the
standard is based on just arbitrary
nonsense it's really based on on
droplets it's not based on airborne
viruses studies done in like the 1930s
and 40s okay so the six foot standard is
meaningless all of the mask studies that
have been done that are showing that
masks are super duper effective are
basically lab studies that that have not
been applied in the real world there's
one study from bangladesh about real
world mass and that did not apply to
delta which is much more infectious than
the original variant and certainly does
not apply to omicron so so much of the
quote-unquote science that is surrounded
this is just based on unfaulty data so
the cdc has now announced that once
you're five days in you can go back to
work but the consideration why why well
because if they force everybody out of
work for omicron it shuts down the
economy again like some of us were
saying several weeks ago that if you
wish to go into soft lockdown test
everybody and force them all to
quarantine for 10 days so anthony fauci
and the cdc accepted that over the
course of the last week
the reason is that now that we have such
an overwhelming volume of cases coming
in many of which are without symptoms
there's the danger that this is going to
have a really negative impact on our
ability
to really get society to function
properly you're hearing reports from
cities throughout the country of
substantial percentages of firefighters
policemen people with critical jobs
who are infected and required to stay
home
in isolation for 10 days so the cdc made
a decision to balance what's good for
public health at the same time as
keeping the society running
so here's the thing if the cdc had taken
that approach from the beginning then
you were killing grandma do you remember
this go all the way back to the
beginning some of us said
try and calm myself down here some of us
said at the beginning you know there are
a bunch of competing priorities here one
is protecting the people who are most
vulnerable the other is making sure we
don't shut down the economy destroy
hundreds of thousands of small
businesses and wreck millions of lives
and if you mention that you're ready to
kill grandma it was all about murder and
grandma if you said that protecting
people who are 80 should be the priority
and that you don't shut down all of
society to protect the people who are
80.
if you said this it's because you wanted
grandma to die
this is what it you remember
now the cdc is and it was people like
fauci saying this well it's all about
saving lloyds you know you got to save
lives that's the only important thing so
you've got to mask up your grandmother
and then even after she's dead you go
into a graveyard you dig it open if
she's dead and you put the mask on her
skull on her moldering skull you might
make sure that her skin doesn't degrade
into some sort of you know something
terrible like she gets covered then she
dies again because even though she's
dead she could die twice it's like
double masking double death you got to
be very she might be mostly dead not
totally dead mostly dead and then she
infects the ground it gets into the
groundwater and then some child in in
upstate new york might get covered
because of that it's very bad
this was the schtick for two years and
now all of a sudden anthony you know
guys we might have to have some so what
changed
what changed the answer is all these
people got covered
that's the answer the answer is all
these people got omicron
now that omicron because they all got
omicron they were like oh
either i'm bad and i have sinned or
alternatively
new data has emerged from the sky
and now i understand that we have to
balance priorities and now that i say it
because i'm one of the good ones we're
all allowed to say it if you said it if
you said it five months ago that's cause
you were bad you should be banned from
social media but if you say it today
it's cause you're good cause he did all
the things we asked a few okay so here's
the thing even that
provides cognitive dissonance for for
too many who are covered lockdown
fanatics they're still too freaked out
they can't deal with it so immediately
upon the left beginning to deal with
reality which by the way is a good thing
okay i'm ripping on them because it's
pathetic that we spent two years
listening to these mewling idiots who
don't bother to follow the data and are
so consumed with their hatred of people
on the other side of the political aisle
that they are willing to rip on decent
policy so long as the person
promulgating the policy has an r next to
their name
i'm not even talking about people who
are anti-vaccine you know ripping on
people who are anti-vaccine and pushing
stuff that's not true about vaccines i'm
saying that they're ripping on ron
desantis for example in florida who was
pushing vaccines and vaccinated the
elderly and protected them better than
the great and sainted
late departed andrew cuomo of grab
assery
right they like the the fact that the
fact that they were so enmeshed in their
they were so engulfed in their own
hatred of everybody who didn't think
like them that they embraced the
position that was anti-data and now that
they have embraced the data-driven
position or started to embrace the data
now it's a good position now you can
take it but here's the thing they can't
deal with even that because once you
have enervated an entire population
those people are too scared they're too
scared we've turned them into into
puddles of humanity these are people who
are scared of their own shadow at this
point and so the pushback has begun and
you're starting to see people on the
left going wait hold up hold up
like we're all getting omicron and you
say omicron isn't that bad but i also
know i'm supposed to be super scared
i've been told for the last two years
that i should be living in abject fear
of this virus whether i'm vaccinated
whether i have natural i should be
living day to day
in in terror that the virus is going to
crash through my door like the kool-aid
man and just
bash me over the skull
with a copy of the cdc handbook that's
what i'm afraid of so how are you guys
loosening up dana bash representative of
this class here she is on cnn trying to
cuddle dr fauci and the cdc back in line
you know maybe you guys shouldn't change
the standard from ten days to five days
maybe you should change it back to ten
days because you know we wouldn't want
to be realistic here at all
these are relaxed quarantined guidelines
that came from the cdc and they're
coming under fire from some public
health experts cnn medical analyst dr
jonathan reiner sent out a tweet saying
quote the latest cdc guidelines which
allow people to leave isolation after
five days without a test remind me of
when the public was told we didn't need
masks when in reality the problem was
the u.s didn't have masks you've always
promised to follow the science dr fauci
is this driven by science or by the
social and business pressure we were
talking about
okay and and fouchy didn't have an
answer for that because obviously
it's a balance of the two
right it's a balance of the two meaning
that the underlying reality of not
testing people after five days and
sending them back into the workforce the
underlying reality is that we're not
trying to stop the spread at this point
and the reason we're not trying to stop
the spread is because we can't and the
reason that we can't is because this
thing is wildly infectious and the very
good news is that it being wildly
infectious and also being not all that
deadly
all right we can all live with that we
can't and if you're particularly
immunocompromised or vulnerable you
should take special precautions for
yourself maybe you should isolate
otherwise we're all gonna go back to
work we're all gonna live our lives and
those of us in florida have been doing
so for literally a year
those western florida been doing so for
well over a year maybe a year and a half
at this point
and um and that's why you're all
vacationing down here you jerks
go back home
go live in your miserable basement being
sad and miserable triple masked while
staring at the walls
and worshiping an icon of same failure
okay but but again the pushback has
begun so now factory begins to walk it
back so within five minutes of saying
yeah we've got to take into account the
actual realities the situation on the
ground all of a sudden fouch is like
well you know maybe we should reconsider
i don't know maybe we should be harsh
again who knows then you will you love
me dana if i say yes will you love me
will you will you love dr anthony i was
on the cover
of in touch magazine that's how special
i am
the likelihood of transmissibility
is considerably lower in that second
half of the phi of of a 10-day period
and for that reason
the cdc made the judgment that it would
be relatively low risk to get people out
you're right people are getting
concerned about why not test people at
that time i myself feel that that's a
reasonable thing to do
i believe that the cdc soon
will be coming out with more
clarification of that since it obviously
has generated a number of questions
about at that five-day period should you
or should you not be testing people
so within five seconds of him
recognizing that reality is reality he's
immediately cuddled back into fantasy
maybe we should have tests of the
asymptomatic to make sure that they're
not transmitting
here's the thing i know people who have
had covet and some of them are testing
positive for covert weeks after the fact
because it turns out that all a covet
test does all a pcr test does is test
your nasal cavity essentially for
presence of the virus
okay but that doesn't mean that it's
transmissible it could be dead virus it
could be virus you've already shed it
also does not mean that that's super
dangerous but it doesn't matter now
we're going to test the asymptomatic
which means back into soft lockdown
meanwhile dr fauchi is going to continue
to maintain the fiction the cloth masks
are super effective against omicron so
now we have a gottlieb and wen versus
fouchy battle here's fauci trying to
uphold the the efficacy of cloth masking
against omicron based on literally zero
data zero
are cotton and surgical masks effective
at preventing the spread of omicron when
the cdc says they are effective in fact
they are are they as effective as an n95
no but what was being said is rather
wear a cotton or a surgical mask than
not wear any mask at all and that's the
point that was made i think it was a
consideration that people were saying if
they're not affected well then don't
wear them they have a degree of
effectiveness and if that's the mask
that's available to you use it
he's provided no data to support this
none
zero and meanwhile in new york by the
way they're considering they're
continuing to maintain their garbage
policy despite the fact that they have
this record spike they have higher
levels of omicron in new york city than
they ever had of delta
i mean they're getting like 40 000 cases
a day in new york city
and bill de blasio on his way out
announced these vax mandates that every
business in new york
was going to need to mandate that all of
its employees were vast now i know a
bunch of business owners in new york
they're just going to relocate because
half their employees are not vast
half their employees have natural
immunity there's no exception for
national natural immunity by the way
according to the new york times
the spike has caused crippling
shortages of workers that have forced
restaurants to close subway lines to
shut down broadway theaters to shutter
concerns about the virus even caused the
westminster kennel club to postpone its
january show the test positivity rate is
above 20
in new york city so what did eric adams
the incoming mayor of new york the great
savior of new york do what did he do he
immediately doubled down and said that
he's going to maintain de blasio's vast
mandate in the city of new york while we
welcome all the actual productive
tax-paying citizens of new york down to
florida please vote like you didn't
while you were in new york
because this is what you could decide to
embrace so the democrats are stuck
between a rock and a hard place they
really are you got ron clayne retweeting
chris hayes saying that omicron is
basically no worse than the flu
meanwhile you got the democrats saying
what if we just continue to soft lock
down everything
what if omicron continue to lock down
everything this is very bad for
democrats right because this is an
election year so you guys can you have
boxed yourselves in you have created an
authoritarian box of your own making and
now you have locked yourself inside but
unlike harry houdini you can't actually
get out so you screwed
we'll get to that in one moment because
the democrats do have a plan is to say a
thing over and over again we'll get to
that in a moment first
right now we have record low mortgage
rates that is not going to last forever
the fed is going to taper they've made
it clear this year they're going to
raise interest rates maybe three times
that means that if you're looking to
refi your mortgage now is the best time
in human history every day that passes
you know what's going to happen we're at
risk of seeing higher rates it will cost
you money please find out what your
options are with my friends at american
financing get a free mortgage review no
obligation whatsoever by calling our
friends at american financing you're
likely to save hundreds if not a
thousand bucks a month and tens of
thousands long term you can choose any
loan term ten years and over so you're
not wasting money on interest a refi
really can save you a lot of money but
you've got to call before the rates get
higher eight six six seven two one
thirty three hundred that's eight six
six
one
or visit americanfinancing.net and mls
182-334-nmlsconsumeraccess.org
again that's americanfinancing.net
one thirty 866-721-3300 hundred or visit
americanfinancing.net that is
americanfinancing.net mls one eight two
three three four mls consumer access dot
org refi your mortgage today and save
yourself some money all right we'll get
some more in just one second first folks
i have a big announcement for you it's
something i'm super excited about so i
know a lot of you are making new year's
resolutions this year one of your
resolutions might be to read more i get
a lot of people who have been emailing
me over the course of years asking about
the kind of books that i'm reading well
as you know i read all the time and i
really believe that the books that we
read help shape our world view which is
why i'm super excited to kick off the
brand new year by announcing my new book
club once a month i'm going to be
recommending a book it has cultural
significance not just new books or
political books classic books as well
some of which the left have chased out
of classrooms these are the key pillars
in the foundation of western society
become a better you by reading the books
that should be on everybody's list and
read them along with me when you join
the book club you'll get access to my
personal notes and analysis of the book
then on the third thursday of each month
i will join daily wire members online
for an in-depth lecture and discussion
of every book don't let this year go by
without investing in yourself 12 books a
year a book a month go to third
thursdaybookclub.com we will send you
this month's book recommendation and
some of the materials you'll need to
participate in the members only
discussion on thursday january 20th
that's third
thursdaybookclub.com i can't wait to
share my passion for reading with you
also do not comply has taken on an
entirely new meaning for the daily wire
this week this friday the supreme court
convenes to hear arguments on the
legality and constitutionality of joe
biden's federal vaccine mandate that
means this week will be pivotal in our
fight against the biden administration's
authoritarian vast mandate we have over
a million signatures on our do not
comply petition we really appreciate
that we would love to see that number
increase dramatically before friday when
you sign the petition at dailywire.com
do not comply you do help us send the
message that the american people will
not comply head on over to dailywire.com
do not comply right now we're counting
on you to help us put a stop to the
disgusting tyrannical federal overreach
that we are currently seeing you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so here is the thing all of the
democratic confusion the norman osborne
green goblin personality split it's just
like the flu no it's not just like the
flu it's going to kill us all no we
can't test that we have to test the
asymptote no no you mustn't they have to
be light out after
watching all this the american public is
having a nervous breakdown and because
we are all having a nervous breakdown
apparently this is having a rather large
toll on businesses and this means that
the democrats are set for a show lacking
in 2022 and they know it according to
the wall street journal the rapid spread
of covet 19's omicron variant is
weighing on u.s businesses keeping more
workers home sick or quarantined leading
some companies to cut services and
reduce hours the rise of kova 19
infections to record levels in recent
days has driven thousands of cancelled
flights prompted retailers to train
available employees on new jobs close
some stores all together
the rapidly spreading omicron variant is
hitting businesses at a time when
consumers demand for products and
services has surged many companies are
already struggling with staffing and
supply chain challenges now let's make
this very clear that's not because of
omicron this was a policy regarding
omicron as always when you treat omicron
as a crisis and send lots of people who
are asymptomatic home and force them to
test when you have tens of thousands of
people getting tests for asymptomatic or
mild colds
you're going to end up with a soft
lockdown this has some rather large
ramifications for most americans
meanwhile stocks face a rockier path in
2022 as a fed rate increase looms
according to the wall street journal
quote the double threat of an
unpredictable pandemic and looming
interest rate increases is tempering
investors optimism heading into 2022 a
contrast to their vaccine and stimulus
fueled enthusiasms of a year ago
investors had plenty to feel good about
over the holidays supported by an
economic rebound even stronger than most
had expected the s p 500 climbed at 27
in 2021
the third largest gain of the past 20
years okay first of all this was not an
economic rebound stronger than most had
expected it was significantly weaker
than most had expected but
heading into 2021 economists surveyed
had expected that the u.s economy would
grow 3.7 percent instead it likely
expanded more than percent but inflation
also expanded massively so the real
growth rates were lower
one major concern of investors how
different problems might feed on each
other fresh waves of coven 19 cases
caused by new or existing variants might
slow economic growth by reducing
consumer spending but some worry such
surges could help sustain already hot
inflation by contributing to supply
chain problems and labor shortages okay
so the democrats confuse policy and
their refusal to just go back to
something
mildly resembling normal
means that they are going to pay the
price because here's the thing
here's why i say it's a problem of
policy it is not a problem of omicron
per se
okay because if you actually look at the
states in the united states that for
example did not engage in the stupidity
of randomly
lengthening the period of unemployment
benefits odd infinitum those states did
fine in terms of job recovery
the states that decided to continue to
support people staying home for covid
those states have not done particularly
well in terms of job
recovery okay according to a wall street
journal piece from the editorial board
over at the wall street journal using
data from the bureau of labor statistics
monthly household survey
early termination of unemployment
led to a 14 percentage point increase in
the flow from unemployment to employment
the unemployment rate among prime age
working americans in the 24 states that
maintained big benefits through labor
day would have been 0.7 percentage
points lower in august had they ended
benefits in june the national
unemployment rate would have been 0.3
percentage points lower had all states
ended benefits early but democrats want
to keep blowing out the spending and
everybody knows it and so democrats are
now in a state of panic because joe
biden's message is not resonating it's
not resonating at all and so this leaves
the democratic media complex with a
problem and the problem is if joe
biden's message is not resonating and if
in fact we're about to see fed rate
increases which means the stock market
doesn't do what it did last year and if
that means that it's going to have an
impact on employment rates which
typically happens when you raise
interest rates employment rates tend to
go down a little bit
okay if all that happens and people are
still paranoid
then the democrats are headed for a
massive red wave in
november and so the media have to do two
things they have to do two things one
they have to somehow save joe biden and
two they have to come up with an
alternative talking point to you know
reality and and current affairs
and they've come up with both of these
so the first thing that they've come up
with is the idea that if you oppose
biden it's because you're very very bad
so over the christmas holiday the
biggest story in america for at least a
couple of days the biggest story in
america is that joe biden was doing some
sort of christmas shtick from the fake
oval office
where he uh where he called up
a bunch of people random people
as santo was supposedly flying over
their houses using the the cute
graphic of
from um from the defense department of
santa flying around
joe biden was calling up random people
and saying can you see santa from your
house and one of the people he called up
proceeded to drop let's go brandon on
him and joe biden because he does not
know what year it is or which country he
lives in or what office he holds joe
biden was like that sounds great i also
like brandon
i hope you guys have a wonderful
christmas as well uh merry christmas and
let's go brandon let's go brandon i
agree
you can see it's dawning on jill right
in that moment that um that that's not
that let's go brandon means f joe biden
and uh joe has no clue i agree let's go
brandon hey so the media made this this
was the worst story ever according to
the media this was the worst thing
happening in america not omicron not the
fact that this guy took off for delaware
after basically abdicating all
responsibility not the fact that
democrats were decamping to florida to
party it up the biggest story in america
is someone said something mildly rude a
euphemism
for fu to joe biden on a public phone
call end of world because no one ever
said anything mean to trump ever no one
in fact american politics has been
replete with civility since the
beginning which is why alexander
hamilton was shot dead in a duel with a
man who was the vice president of the
united states
so yeah there was there was that you
know
but but you know it's this was the worst
thing i mean the number of think pieces
the number of think pieces
about
let's go brandon because the idea here
again is that in the end all democrats
have is their under incentive moral
superiority that's all they have those
are all the things they don't have the
efficacy they don't have a record of
success here all they have is the
unearned moral superiority and scare
tactics which is why they are panicking
and they are freaking out and so now
their new move is they're going to try
to essentially change voting procedures
to make it easier for democrats to win
that's their new move their new move is
and there's only one way they can do
that and that is by shifting the topic
of conversation which is what this week
is going to be all about because they're
panicked right what are they panicked
over they're panicked over the fact that
republicans are about to take congress
and if republicans take congress one of
the things that they might do is ban
things like ballot harvesting which is a
super corrupt practice by which
democrats basically hire a bunch of
activists to go door to door to people
who did not order an absentee ballot but
were sent an absentee ballot by the
democrats in the state legislature they
go door to door they pick up the ballots
now that's a recipe for voter fraud
it's a recipe for it because you're just
going to somebody's door and you know
that person's a registered democrat and
you tell them how to vote and then they
hand you the ballot or they hand you the
ball and you fill it out for them
they're ballot harvesting is a really
corrupt practice by the way it's been
used by both republicans and democrats
depending on where you are just across
the board democrats wish to enshrine
that republicans wish to avoid that so
democrats are panicking
and democrats are looking at 2022 and
they know that their window of
opportunity closes in 2022 because there
is a very good shot that come to come
the election in november
they're in real trouble
right and they and they can't stand it
they know a bad year is coming i think
by the way you know who knows more than
anybody else that a bad year is coming
as don lemon from cnn so don lemon he
knows a bad year is coming so he was
ripping on his haters don lemon the
worst anchor in in american news here he
was on new year's eve drunk as a skunk
then those trusted nervous here we go
i don't give a
what you think about me what do you
think about i don't care i'm a grown ass
man i don't care what you think about me
i'm alive i am who i am i'm a grown
successful black man who a lot of people
hate because then i use people seeing
me people like me in a position
to be able to share what i my point of
view on television it freaks people out
and you know what you can kiss my behind
i do not care i don't care yeah he
doesn't care and you know what his lack
of care the media's lack of care the
democrats lack of care it means they're
about to get a whoopin come november
that election is gonna be fun to watch
as a conservative it's gonna be very
very or is it just a reasonable person i
think it could be very fun to watch so
democrats have to they in in short order
democrats must come up with an
alternative so here is the alternative
democrats have come up with are you
ready for it you ready here we go it is
wait for it wait for it wait for it
january 6th
that's the alternative january 6th if
the democrats just say january 6th over
and over like beetlejuice into the
mirror it will suddenly appear
and then if january 6th appears then all
will be made right with the world
because you will remember that donald
trump is a bad man even though donald
trump isn't on the ballot and isn't
running for office this year
and even though
you are much more concerned over whether
your real wages decreased over the
course of the last year and even though
you're much more worried about whether
your business is still going to be open
this year or whether you're allowed to
send your kid to school or they're going
to mask up your four-year-old even
though you're worried about those things
what you really should be laser focused
on is the fact that some idiots and
drugs who went into the capitol building
on january 6 were quickly expelled by
the police within
a couple of hours and then joe biden was
certified as the election winner that's
what you're supposed to remember huge
vastly important and the media and
democrats they are always on message the
propagandistic media is in it is it is
an incredible thing
so cnn is doing an entire capital
celebration
of january 6th a commemoration and it
really is a celebration because they're
so happy this thing happened they are so
happy that the capitol building was
invaded
they're so happy about that the reason
they're so happy about that is because
they get to talk about it and try to
proclaim that no matter how bad
democrats are at governing at least
they're not in league with weird
wagnerian helmet guy
at least at least they're not in league
with
barbarian drug
bear chested in the capital in the
capital rotunda guy
right this is this is their final pitch
so according to cnn
several lawmakers and members of the law
enforcement community tasked with
protecting the us capital will mark the
one-year anniversary of the deadly
insurrection there next month during a
live event hosted by cnn the network
announced thursday so first of all the
deadly insurrection let's just make
clear
in
first of all calling it in insurrection
is is a bit of an overstatement because
typically when you talk about an
insurrection you're talking about a
military attack on a on an installation
not a bunch of idiots walking in unarmed
and selfieing themselves while they're
in the building that does not mean there
weren't people attacking cops there were
people attacking cops there are some
cops that were injured the thing that
made it deadly by the way the only
person who was actually killed during
that entire
that entire debacle was ashley babbitt
who was one of the rioters that she was
shot to death
all the other officers who died that day
or in the surrounding days there's no
evidence that they died because of
january 6th that is not to downplay what
january 6 was i think it was an awful
image for the united states i thought it
was a terrible image for the rest of the
world i thought it was ugly i thought it
was i thought it was stupid i thought it
had nothing to do with reality
i thought it was propagated by there was
i thought that the the people who were
there were operating under assumptions
that were untrue propagated by the
presidents of the united like all of
that is that does not make it a deadly
insurrection right but that's how cnn is
going to cover it
okay so
they're not covering the one-year
anniversary they didn't cover last
summer or the one-year anniversary of
the black lives matter riots that cost
five billion dollars in uninsured
property damage
and uh and ended with the deaths of of i
believe a couple of dozen people
but they are going to have a full-on
inauguration style coverage of the
one-year anniversary of two of
a few hundred people
breaking the windows at the capitol
building and then being expelled by the
capitol police who got there laid
live from the capitol january 6th one
year later will air on january 6 2022
exactly one year after the riot quote
honoring the heroes who protected our
democracy in the face of an insurrection
according to a release okay so i look
forward to the interview
with vice president mike pence and
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
both of whom were in charge of the
actual certification of the election the
two-hour conversation will feature nancy
pelosi as well as democratic
representatives lisa blunt rochester of
delaware jason grove colorado veronica
escobar of texas ruben gallego of
arizona dan kildee of michigan and susan
wilde of pennsylvania
wow sounds riveting
riveting riveting stuff
now again the real reason that the
democrats are doing this is made clear
by politico today they have to drive the
panic the panic is that we are on the
verge of the overturn of democracy here
in the united states democracy is on its
last legs now here is the thing there
was no institutional support for the
people who went in the capital they are
all going to jail many of them have
already been sentenced many of them are
still sitting in jail awaiting trial
and there was no major corporate media
support for this
none
this notion that there are like a bunch
of people on tv cheering it on
find them
where are they
even the much
maligned fox news hosts who were
supposedly supportive of this were were
apparently texting donald trump direct
being like stop this crap
there there was no the entire corporate
world with regard to black lives matter
put out statements in support of black
lives matter
narrate a word about the violence about
the looting about the murders nothing
nothing
by the way based on a giant lie that
america's law enforcement is
systemically racist which is the sole
reason why you have a discrepancy and a
disparity between the number of blacks
and whites in prison when it came to
january 6 which has no institutional
support
that is the threat to the democracy
and they have to they have to up threat
right they have to talk about how deep
the threat was and this is why you have
politico reporting all of these various
polls showing
that america is on the precipice of
disaster precipice we're all going to
die it's the end it's the end unless
democrats if democrats retain power
everything will be fine if republicans
take power all will end
according to politico roughly four in
ten republicans and independents say
that violent action against the
government is sometimes justified
according to a startling new washington
post university of maryland poll
overall the percentage of americans who
save violence action against the
government is justified at times stands
at 34
which is considerably higher than in
past polls by the post or other major
news organizations again the view is
partisan the news survey finds 40
percent of republicans 41 of
independents 23 of democrats saying
violence is sometimes justified by the
way that is a two broad poll question
the question is not is violence
justified right now the question is is
violence against the government
sometimes justified in a country where a
revolution was literally fought against
the prevailing government the answer is
yes sometimes violence against the
government is justified it depends on
what the government is trying to do is
the answer that doesn't mean violence
right now it doesn't mean violence based
on current policy
but i think it would be hard-pressed to
say that violence against say the state
government of alabama in 1861
was unjustified i feel like it was kind
of justified wasn't it i mean they were
propagating slave holding
so again treating that is like oh my god
it's all gonna
get the dead giveaway in that particular
polls that 41 of independents agree with
republicans
okay then there's another poll a new cbs
yougov poll finds 68 of respondents see
the january 6th attacks as a harbinger
of increasing political violence not an
isolated incident well you can't lament
the message that you guys have been
promoting being taken up by the american
public you guys keep saying over and
over it's the end of democracy and then
you pull americans they're like well i
guess it's the end of democracy like my
god i'm shocked they say it's the end of
democracy
do you keep telling them that guys
here's my favorite poll stat you ready
12 of the country a fifth of trump's
2020 voters want trump to fight to
retake the presidency right now before
the next election a third of the people
within that 12 percent say he should use
force if necessary
four percent of the population
but that amounts to millions of
americans
um
question what's the margin of error
the margin of error on these types of
polls is typically two to four percent
so in other words the answer is pretty
much no one thinks that donald trump
should initiate a violent coup against
the american government they're like
well i gotta panic it's at four percent
like 10 of americans still think elvis
is alive what are you talking about
the cbs crosstabs are equally telling
says politico
among democrats 85 called the right in
insurrection in which people are trying
to overthrow the government
among republicans only 21 said that 18
said they were trying to
overthrow the government gop voters were
more likely to say the rioters were
motivated by defending freedom or
patriotism
okay well maybe that's because
everything is completely and utterly
reactionary and so you guys keep talking
january 6th and so a bunch of people on
the right are like well then it must be
good if you guys hate it okay in any
case what is this really about what this
is really about for the democrats is
pushing forward they're rejiggering a
federal voting law
that's why they're pushing this so hard
and media is complicit the new york
times has an entire piece called every
day is january 6th now every day
now if it is for you it's because you're
a crazy person i mean i don't know if
you are bill murray and you're waking up
in washington dc and every time you hit
that clock
in mind and it's january 6th again my
god the insurrection has begun
no
no but for the new york times they wish
they wish it to be january 6th every day
because january 6 was a day the
republicans were the worst
and it's not today
it is not in fact january 3rd 2022 it is
january 6 2021 forever because that was
the day they had to be the best people
in the world because they weren't you
and you weren't there you weren't the
person who broke into the capitol you
may have thought that sucked you may
have criticized but you were with them
weren't you because you're not with us
and that's all that matters the new york
times is a piece quote
one year after the smoke and broken
glass the mock gallows and the very real
bloodshed of that awful day it is
tempting to look back and imagine what
we can in fact simply look back
to imagine that what happened on january
6th was horrifying but that it is in the
past and that we as a nation have moved
on that is an understandable impulse
after four years of chaos cruelty and
incompetence culminating in a pandemic
and the once unthinkable trauma of
january 6 most americans were desperate
for some peace and quiet
i love that sentence but it culminated
in a pandemic right it's trump's fault
pandemic
four years of chaos and cruelty and
incompetence that was the worst
administration i mean sure we had a
booming economy and sure we didn't
engage in any foreign wars but it was uh
trump did tweets mean crap
says the new york times on the surface
we've achieved peace and quiet really i
feel like people are kind of unhappy the
president has a 41 approval rating our
political life seems more or less normal
these days as the president pardons
turkeys and congress squirrels over
spending bills but peel back a layer and
things are far from normal january 6th
is not in the past it is every day
every day
and so we must look forward
hundreds of bills have been proposed
nearly three dozen laws have been passed
that empower state legislatures to
sabotage their own elections overturn
the will of their voters some bills
would change the rules to make it easier
for lawmakers to reject the votes of
their citizens if they don't like the
outcome by the way those bills have not
passed others replace professional
election officials with partisan actors
yet more attempt to criminalize human
errors by election officials in some
cases even threatening prison
thus the capital riot continues in state
houses across the country in a bloodless
legalized form no police officer can
arrest no prosecutor can try in court
this is why what we need is to kill the
filibuster this is what they say
they say democrats hold unified power
they're not confronting the urgency of
the moment
what we have to do is basically kill the
filibuster and then we have to pass a
bunch of new laws including the for the
people act which is the
voting the voting act that would
completely rejigger voting in the united
states that's what they want
so their solution is they know they're
going to lose in 2022 so they're going
to rig the rules they're going to rig
the rules by shouting that if they don't
rig the rules january 6th will happen
every day
right this is their stick
for example benny thompson
who's the january 6th chairman
representative
he says that the he says that january
6th could happen again he's deeply
worried january 6th could happen again
hmm
interesting okay because um i i have
noticed that some democrats have denied
election results in the past but
apparently this is the only day that has
ever happened it's january just like the
world began turning the day that donald
trump was elected it apparently ceased
turning on january 6th
it's amazing
donald trump is the center of these
people's universe and and now he's not
there so i guess he's just a black hole
at the center of their universe here we
go
are you worried
that an attack on our democracy like
we're seeing right there with our own
two eyes
on january 6 last year could happen
again
going forward
yes i am uh i committed to it the
capital
we saw uh all those points and some
others that's not in that video
that really causes a significant concern
that unless we get it right uh given the
attitude of what's occurring in this
country now uh it could happen again
okay so what's their solution their
solution of course is rig the voting
procedures and this is their their
actual solution just like they did in
pennsylvania right they they avoided the
pennsylvania state constitution and
simply crammed down the everybody gets
to vote absentee we have to have drop
boxes everywhere ballot harvesting up
the wazoo this is what they would do
federally and the way that they're going
to gin up support for this is by
claiming that if they don't do this
every election will be you have to let
us steal the next election so that you
don't steal the election
if we steal you can't steal it right
that that is the logic here
so this is why cnn is hosting retired
general stephen anderson saying that the
military might facilitate a 2024 threat
from within if this is alarmist bullcrap
it's just not true
um you know there's there's a threat
within we've got some people that just
haven't been educated
they haven't been found out and they're
they've grown in power
through perhaps inaction
on the parts of some of our key leaders
and we need to do what we can do now to
identify those people get them out of
our ranks and train the rest of the
force on civics 101 about how our
country is supposed to work how
elections work stop listening to the
pillow guy and start
learning about our country and how it's
actually supposed to run it's a threat
within the military it's a threat that's
coming directly from okay so again if
you ramp up the alarmism what do you get
you get to do all the things that you
wanted to do which is really what it's
about as political reports today quote
it's going to be an emotional week for a
lot of people on capitol hill but the
one year anniversary of the january 6
capital siege thursday congress is
planning an array of memorials and
speeches to commemorate one of the
darkest days in american history okay it
was a very dark day in american history
it was not in fact one of the top five
to ten darkest days in american history
uh you know the the reason that i say
that is because we've had some pretty
dark days and we've had presidents
who've been assassinated john f kennedy
had his head blown off in public we've
had
literally i mean the senate building was
bombed in the 1970s get a giant civil
war in this country we had a century of
jim crow
like this one is not at the top of the
list but
if you exaggerate the threat you have to
do what you want to do democrats are
hoping thursday will be more than just a
day of remembrance in the senate we hear
from well-positioned sources there's a
desire to take the opportunity to
supercharge the party's long-stalled
voting rights legislation
possibly even using the anniversary to
try to get senators kirsten cinema and
joe manchin to go nuclear on the
filibuster or embrace rules changes
senate majority leader chuck schumer is
expected to lay out a plan today that
will bring the party's push to
nationalize voting rights protections to
the floor in the coming days
all week democrats will argue that a
flurry of voting restrictions that have
passed in gop-controlled states over the
last year are a direct result of the
january 6th riots and the big lie
promulgated by former president donald
trump and that democracy is still very
much on the line
so we have to kill the filibuster
and then we have to cram through a bill
that's going to el that's not only going
to allow it's going to mandate mandate
that states allow ballot harvesting
across the spectrum for example
and that absentee ballots are sent
directly to your house regardless
whether you requested one or not
and that the time of voting be expanded
dramatically even though we really all
should be voting on on
election day
this is required you have to let us
change all the rules about voting so
that you don't steal democracy you have
to guys to save democracy because a
bunch of people went into the capitol
building and tried to be police officers
and now go to jail
or already in jail because that happened
you have to let us kill the filibuster
in the senate
overhaul america's voting procedures and
federalize everything
that's how to save democracy if you
allow us to kill democracy it will 100
save democracy
this is what they are talking about
right now
some democrats think an argument pegged
to january 6th could win over cinema and
mansion the party's two major holdouts
against making an end run around the
filibuster
schumer has signaled that when the bill
goes down it will open a debate about
changing senate rules to enable passage
of voting measures without the chamber
60 vote threshold
that debate could push into next week as
the party puts the squeeze on cinema and
mansion will this work probably not
it probably won't work
but at the very least
they will have shifted the conversation
with the help of the entire democrat
media complex that's their hope here's
the thing it ain't going to work
democrats are headed for a very very bad
2022 they the ones who know it know it
and uh and no matter how much they tried
to misdirect over to january 6th it
turns out january 6 happened a full year
ago and no one's gonna care more people
are going to be worried
about their pocketbook then they're
going to be worried about
the people who decided to invade the
capitol building january 6 2021 when we
hit november 2022. alrighty we'll be
back here later today with much more
content in the meantime go check out the
michael knowles show that is available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show and happy new year
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feldt executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
krand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
i along with everybody else got the
rhona the ruling class completely
changed its covet propaganda and no less
a lecherous country than france prepares
to ban porn check it out in the michael
knowles show
[Music]